I think it's a really important
distinction cuz you're basically drawing
the line between what's over and
optimizing for the government is
optimizing for safe jobs the private
equity investor is optimizing for return
on investment and save the company right
and actually those two things are in
some cases actually opposite of what you
would do from an action perspective when
you fire everyone the other you keep
everyone and so it's trying to
understand how do you you know basically
get people to do the right thing and
keeping the jobs which is against kind
of the capitalistic view of safety
company at all cost it is and look they
I mean there was a solution to this and
we'll see maybe on the bigger loan
package was we haven't seen the rules
yet a solution would have been of course
taking some sort of equity in the
companies but would the PPP program is
still pretty small I mean again you know
if you're a 400 person private equity
backed company again the maximum loan is
10 million bucks if 10 million dollars
is the different swings you know living
and dying that it's probably not the
case this is still for mostly for small
businesses and the federal government I
just from a logistics standpoint does
not want equity in you know 80,000 small
businesses across America yeah and so I
guess then that brings the question of
like is there concern around like the
extremists would say hey this is
nationalizing large corporations right
whether it's United Boeing you know
those types of companies but at the
other side would be well actually the
taxpayer should have all of the exposure
to the benefit of their capital being
used right so whether it's debt with
warrants whatever kinda how does that
playing out or what an investor saying
they're like I'm partial to that I think
the government should get equity if
you're giving billions of dollars to a
big corporation that should damn well
get equity then the upside shouldn't all
be for the shareholders ah you know it's
interesting
a Boeing CEO and God you know every day
now is like a lifetime in this world but
I want to say this like three weeks ago
before the cares Act was passed Boeing
CEO got asked about this he said oh if
their equity strings attached we're just
not going to take it into money we have
all these better options he never
explained what any of the better options
were we asked Boeing repeatedly no one
could quite answer that question it
seems if you had better options you
would take the matter options like if I
have a better option that's what I
usually take why wouldn't I it's a
better option so like I look at in the
government sure the government had
equity stay excited you know through
tarp it had equity stakes in the auto
bailout in certain cases in GM and yeah
it's an activist
Wester asked anybody at GM if the
government was a passive or active
investor was an active investor it
should have been it was a lot of money
was a lot of taxpayer money it ended up
making people money back you know the
the federal government ultimately made
money on the financial bailouts of o.9
on the on the auto bailouts um so it's
not a bad yeah but I of course there
should be equity for the big chests why
shouldn't there be it shouldn't all be
private shareholders who benefit from
this yeah and what happened to the
equity in those cases so I couldn't GM's
case or whatever do they basically hold
the equity until there's like debt paid
back and then they sell the equity or
how does that work yeah they ultimately
decide to sell it
um you know every situation is different
you know you what you really want is the
underlying entity to be stable but yeah
eventually they sell it and they sell it
you know either on the open market
theoretically you could sell back to the
company hell in theory itself to a
private equity firm but um yeah they
eventually sold it and they were very
public about it they did it in pieces
etcetera but yeah at once once the
company is stable and there is a market
for it again the government sells it
hopefully to profit yeah and I guess
really this then brings a question of
like okay we get the first kind of wave
of stimulus two trillion dollars I'm
assuming that there's gonna have to be
more over time it's soon like they're
already closed has already got a plan
out the cares Act - it's coming it's
coming quickly because almost everybody
agrees that what was in the first one
wasn't enough money because there's also
all sorts of like in the first one there
was you know there was Hospital bailout
money which is desperately needed there
is going to be more of that needed
states and municipalities there was
money for them there's gonna have to be
tons more of that think about if you're
a municipality that makes most of your
money off of sales and tourism taxes or
not most but a huge amount of your money
off sales and tourism taxes your city's
been shut down for three weeks but
you're still paying your teachers your
cops your firemen your sanitation
workers and everybody the same out what
and and you have to balance your budget
usually legally if you're a municipality
or state and you have bonds that are due
what are you gonna do about that you're
going to need a bailout and only one
entity in America can print money the
the metric I saw or the article was
talking with the MTA how the MTA
basically saying like locally nobody's
read in subway it's down 90 percent
right if we have 90 percent drop in
ridership how the hell we're gonna pay
the bonds and by the way for airports as
well airports as well oh really okay
yeah it works out boggs have built them
and they collect that you know when you
get your airline ticket from JetBlue or
United whatever part of what you
four is actually the operations the
airport there's a sea in there those
fees are obviously down eighty percent
got it and what are you hearing from
like private equity investors venture
capitalists in terms of how does this
change the landscape of just business
investing in general what I mean by that
is you know there's obvious stuff hey
people gonna start asking is your
company pandemic proof rather than
recession proof type stuff right but
actually does this make people more
gun-shy or people getting you know kind
of salivating and say hey we're gonna
get more aggressive here we think
there's gonna be some cheap buys but
what do you see from from a strategy
standpoint across different firms on the
venture capital side on the early-stage
side I haven't seen all that much of a
change um yeah obviously the the
mechanics of doing things are different
people aren't talking on planes and
hanging out it you know YC networking
parties anymore so in the Kansas change
but there's actually been a pretty
decent amount of VC activity in the last
few weeks admittedly not as much as
there was before this um decent amount
particularly on the biotech side so you
know cuz if you're a pre-revenue company
you haven't necessarily been affected
yet cuz you who aren't selling anything
to start with a bunch of the later stage
venture deals have blown up there's no
doubt about that over pricing because no
one really knows what the what anything
is worth now then on the round the but
the buyouts have largely slowed down
there's some there's no getting done new
ones are pretty rare for two reasons one
is the pricing issue you know what is
this thing worth and then B there's a
debt issue there's a question of whether
you can issue whether you can issue new
junk bonds or new high-yield bonds which
is usually what private equity deals get
done with there's been a lot of these
junk bond funds raised in the last
couple weeks but very little new
issuance because remember the banks have
to issue it and then they usually
syndicated out and find other buyers and
they are not at all convinced yeah and I
guess really wouldn't sup happening is
if all of the over leveraged in the
private equity companies is just
applying more pressure to them getting
the relief they need because you know if
you look at some of these retail
restaurants for somebody you've made I
mean we're talking revenue going to zero
it's not like hey it's down 30 percent
just because people are going out a
little less zero where do you get the
money to pay you know two or three
months of your debt payment you know
these are huge issues because you know
it's certain companies just happened to
be managed very very well and happened
to have a massive rainy day fund or more
likely we're really lucky when they
raised right they raised money in
January and thank God they raise money
and weren't planning to do it at April
no but it's an enormous problem you know
in the financial crisis the leverage the
the private equity back deals actually
survive most of them survive there were
some big bankruptcies but a lot of them
survived because what the bank said was
okay look almost none of you can make
your debt payments so we have a choice
either we can assume the companies which
we don't really want to do because among
other things we don't have any internal
way to manage company X or Y or what
we'll do is what they started calling
amend and extend which is okay your debt
payment was due in April it's now gonna
be due next April we're gonna add a
point or half a point of interest on to
it but we're basically and push you off
and and in theory you could do that
again this time except that this time
you have debt payments from everybody do
it once and everybody wants to extend
municipalities want to every corporate
does investment-grade and junk bond
individuals who have home mortgages who
have carbons the entire system there's
so much pressure on it on the lender
side they can't amend and extend
everybody and if they did in theory if
they did well you'd end up is that
liquidity crunch that we were all
freaked out about 2009 where banks just
stopped lending in this case would you
be justified because they have no money
because no one's making the interest
payments which is then you know rolls
back out into the economy